hello I'm Becky Parker I'm head of
physics at Simon lights and grammar
school for boys in can't be in England
and I'd like to ask what area of physics
do you think will throw up the most
fundamental breakthrough in the next 10
years I mean the thought in the presses
or what will be the Higgs boson if they
find it at the LHC but in your view
what's going to be the most significant
breakthrough what area wants the most
significant breakthrough in physics over
the next ten years which will really
transform our understanding of the
universe and how it works thank you well
hi Becca you're asking me do I have a
good crystal ball and the answer is no I
don't really but I can tell you what are
the some of the most exciting questions
that are open right now the question of
whether the Higgs boson really exists
and can be found with a hadron collider
that's clearly one of the big ones and
it would be just as important to find
out if it doesn't exist as if it does
many people think that would be an even
bigger breakthrough if all our theories
are wrong then if we find out that we
were right all along other big
breakthroughs that could happen well
people could possibly discover a dark
matter in the laboratory dark matter is
something astronomers can can discover
we know that it's out there we've never
seen a single particle of it that we
know of in the laboratory so could could
we do that maybe yes then we have a huge
mystery about the dark energy we can
call the force that causes the universe
to accelerate ever faster every year the
dark energy we don't know what that is
we could measure it and probably will
measure it much better in about a decade
there isn't even a possibility of
getting more information about the Big
Bang itself there's a proper property of
the Big Bang radiation which we call the
cosmic background radiation is called
polarization the same sort of property
that you would observe in the sky with
Polaroid sunglasses when we can measure
that really well we have the hope of
understanding much better weather there
are gravitational waves moving around in
the Big Bang material in the first sub
microsecond of the expanding universe so
if we can find out these things there
are possibilities of breakthroughs in
all of them and then of course there's
the possible
that there's something I didn't even
think of which will become even more
surprising so I think we have to wait a
decade in Becky before we know the
answer to your question